good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday we have made it to the back
half of the week give yourself a pat on
the back
acknowledge the space that you're in uh
we've made it to the back half of the
week so give yourself a pat on the back
we're over the hump feels so good this
week really did chug along slowly but
now it's all downhill from here
happy birthday to the snatchler yes it
is a big day here at the morning toast
our co-worker confidante counselor
margot our sister it is her birthday
today so make sure to wish margaret
happy birthday margo we
love you we love you and so dearly if
you haven't ever seen anybody let her
know that we talked about her on the
show just let her know
that we love her so dearly and we hope
that she's the best day ever and that's
all that we said
yeah and she'll never hear this because
she's not um a supportive
counselor but
she'll hear it through the grapevine
people like to let her know people like
to let her know only when we say like
borderline mean stuff which we never do
but we're giving you
full permission to let her know that we
spoke about her today just wishing her
the best
on her birthday it's always exciting
when it's the snitch's birthday
yeah and you know i'm gonna say
something kind of crazy like i think i'm
much more of a stevie wonder happy
birthday girl
than like the generic one like when i i
was just about to sing i was gonna say
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday like i just think that
song's better and i said what i said and
i meant it
yeah well she might not watch it today
but it's also archie mountbatten
windsor's birthday today i'm sorry
what archie mountbatten windsor oh
it's his birthday today so maybe meghan
markle's baby meghan markle's
bed maybe he'll be watching and he gets
a little taste of your beautiful sauce
imagine if archie grew up to be a
toaster i could see it crazier things
have happened
so happy birthday to everyone whose
birthday it is today only counselor
snitch
mainly counselors niche but also archie
but also archie
um i am excited for today's show we of
course have like so much to talk about
the real housewives of new jersey was on
last night
followed by like one of the best
episodes of watch weapons live i've seen
definitely from
remote studios um it was the real house
husbands of new jersey it was just a
great episode so we're gonna dive into
all that during the tv recap
i watched a little bit of the bull type
yesterday i was so busy
filming this vlog for patreon and like
it was killing me because i hate being
busy but also because i was like i want
to be watching the bold type so only got
to watch one episode before bed that's
the best feeling when you have something
that you're so
into that you can't wait to get back to
it and it's like juicy one-hour episodes
well
45 minutes with commercials but how many
seasons are there
i think three at least and it's coming
back soon oh it's still on
yeah oh my god that is so exciting
yeah someone told me that like you know
jane gets better in the fourth season so
i think there maybe is already four
oh then maybe there's four already i
just love diving into a big fat juicy
like show with like
hour-long episodes six seasons 22
episodes like when i watch lost it's all
there waiting for you
but i was busy because i was vlogging
for our patreon yesterday because
so i have a closet organizers who come
like maybe once or twice a year because
of cove but i haven't seen them in like
18 months like the last time
they were there kate was pregnant and
now her kid is like
going to college like like so i haven't
seen him in so long in my closet
is i was actually ashamed of myself like
for letting it get that bad like none of
my cabinets closed it was just
pandemonium and i can't even blame ben
because it was me too um we reorganize
my whole closet it really looks like a
sickening instagramer's closet like
that's the closet i deserve like i'm an
elegant sometimes queen like sometimes
so i did the whole process went through
found the weirdest [ __ ]
for those who have already seen the
video and wanted to know what the tarp
was that i found
yes i actually thought for a second ben
had joined a cult and was in charge of
pr claudia i took a picture of the thing
and i was going to post on my story is
ben and a cult but then i forgot
and i was going to text you is better
nicole and i forgot but is ben
in a cult i found this like weird tarp
that he had brought home
like a few days ago and he said don't
throw this out so it's obviously
important to him
and it opened up it's this huge tarp
looks like when they set up for a step
and repeat it has like logos but it's
just this one symbol and i was thinking
i'm like does he run the events for a
cult
is he doing pr for a cult so uh he said
i could get rid of it
and he told me when he got home he was
like working on set like a few weeks ago
uh for some like video shoot and they
told him he could keep it and he like
wanted it i have no idea like honestly
his answer
just made me have more questions totally
that's
concerned but all i care about is that i
got to throw it away like i'm in a
closet clean out
me personally i had 10 garbage bags full
of donations like
i felt then had three like
whatever i don't want to get into it but
i'm i throw everything away and then
like years later i'm like where was that
really important sentimental thing and
i'm like oh i probably threw it away
like
that's my crossbar and ben's across the
bear is like he'll literally keep a
receipt from 72 years ago and he'll know
exactly where it is so yeah
different strokes but it felt so good to
get it done my closet looked so good i
did before and after shots i vlogged the
whole thing it was super fun i got a
little
of my coffee drama in there because it
was just like a really busy day so
check that out patreon.com that's the
first episode for the month of may
so good i really enjoyed watching it you
inspired me
not to do anything yet but like to think
about doing something it's just the
worst when like
you know like your closet clean out is
coming up like you're just gonna have to
do it
soon and to know that like it feels like
you i'm kipper like i'm on the other
side of my closet clean out like
364 more days probably till my next one
it feels so good
i'm so happy for you i really and truly
am it's the best feeling
it is my nose is so itchy today my
allergies are just
they're like my zyrtec has been kicking
in the last five days but
the allergies they came for me this week
they came in such a real way i'm so
sorry
it's okay i'm on the mend but it was
tough for a second but so if you see me
scratching my nose like i'm not picking
it i'm just like having a cheetos no i
scratch my nose like literally all the
time on the toast and like sometimes i'm
not gonna lie like i
am picking it um but a rum takes care he
knows not to
you know i was like watching to wait for
this to wait for the camera to go off me
so i could scratch but you know what i'm
just gonna be real with you guys like i
might scratch my nose on my close-up
and i'm not picking it like it's just my
allergies no normalize
scratching in and around your nostrils
but not it not being nose picking yeah
like we should have
wait no or like you pick your nose with
your index finger
but all other fingers like if i if i'm
using my pinky just know
it's a scratch okay i think that's a
good signal that way we don't have to
like address it all the time
yeah no but like and that way if someone
like takes a screenshot it's just like
it looks weird it's not cranky it looks
weird not yeah
that's just like a lot of thinking like
oh my nose is itchy i'm just like i'm a
human i'll go scratch it but no i'm like
oh let me switch my finger i think i can
do it
i think you can too i think because i'm
like so self-conscious of it but i'm
really glad you brought that up normally
normalize scratching in and around your
nostrils yeah like not everything
is a nose pick booger moment no no
sometimes it is though for sure but like
i think
i feel like boogers is like more of a
hobby and not like a compulsi like
something that like
you if you don't do it that second like
you're in pain
do you know what i mean can i speak sure
do you pick your nose like in private no
not with my finger but like i will grab
a tissue and just like go that's not
picking your nose that's like blowing
your nose no i'll go ham up in there
with a tissue no i definitely like
especially when i was a kid like i was
such a closeted nose picker like
you really wouldn't see me do it in
public but like you would not believe
how much time i spent in my bedroom
taking my nose and i'm proud to say like
as an adult like i've
i definitely am way less but i
definitely still pick my nose for sure
but also like if you're doing it in your
bedroom alone like that's your business
that's your business you've almost no
explanation you know ben had a booger
wall
in your home no oh my god when he was a
kid oh
okay like you know you put the boogers
behind your um like bed frame or
something and then like when you move
six years later your parents find your
burger wall
stuff that is so disgusting um no but
what you do
in the privacy of your own home is your
business and you owe us no explanation
no but i share everything like what i
was about to do on this couch like i
owed everyone an explanation yes this is
a public forum it was a scratch
that happened lost my mind and started
picking my notes on the show when
just know like when and if the day comes
that jackie starts picking her nose on
the show like
the end of the show is very close by
like the final we will be closing down
the show i i totally
obviously in such like a negative
headspace if you start doing that like
your mental health obviously a priority
i
don't
care about the show i don't care about
myself like it's
it's i'm in a bad spot i just like i'm
touching my nose a lot now that we're
like talking about it
okay yeah no i feel it we can we can um
other than all of that yesterday what
did i do oh i caught up on all the
episodes of new jersey that i had missed
i did go for a run on a treadmill and it
was fantastic
where oh you're working in my building's
gym i got a slot and
i went for a run on the treadmill using
a peloton tread class
oh tread clasp no it's not the peloton
tread but i pull it up once
you learn nothing i pull it up on my
phone and then i use the treadmill i was
extra cautious after yesterday's um
conversation and it was a really great
workout i'm really into switching it up
right now
fabulous i really just like slaved away
in
the closet all day and then
got like so much work done i forgot to
do like one of my tick tocks it was
really sad because i think i know people
were really upset oh what was the tech
talk you were supposed to do
i've been starting this other new series
here's what you missed on the morning
toast in 60 seconds or less
just for people you know who maybe don't
know about the toast bite-sized toast
bite-sized
crumb the morning crumb so i forgot to
do that yesterday
but what was it going to say
you were about to say something so
somebody posted this in the toast after
dark or else i'd never would have seen
it
some you know this meme going around of
like the longest coffee order ever
starbucks baristas are sharing their
experiences with customers
who literally have the longest orders
like the stickers on
the drinks like go all the way down yeah
but so
then this article was like writing about
the meme i think it was a yahoo article
and then they were talking about like
trying coffee on tick tock is so trendy
tick tocker claudia ashrae tries a new
beverage every day and i'm like
did you just call me a tick tucker i
think that's it official dreams have
been realized i'm moving to la
and i'm proud to announce i'll be
joining the hype house i think gonna
love netflix
i think you're gonna love it there
they're having a new netflix show so
it's so funny they have a netflix
reality show netflix is like really
investing in reality shows
they have one um on netflix and like
so the hype house in it's when when kobe
first started it was like addison
charlie
what it is now it's like literally like
six people i don't know who any of them
are like all the cool people left so
it's not cool anymore
there is another house where all the
boys from hype house went it's called
sway house they're like sponsored by
triller
but like a bunch of losers are left in
the hype house but like
they're losers compared to like the big
names yes but they're still like if you
join the hype house like you would
reach a level of tick-tock fame like
it's something you would reach a lot of
followers i don't know if you would
you wouldn't reach tick-tock fame yeah
maybe yeah tick-tock yeah not real
specifically tick-tock so when netflix
announced that they got a reality show
like the tick tockers went wild because
hype house is like literally a joke and
people
were furious that high pass got a season
one but the society never got a season
two
and literally like that was like the
cause like people were
furious about that in particular and i'm
so glad that the gen z's on millennial
i mean the gen z's on tick tock like
have their priorities in order me too
i'm glad to hear that people have not
given up
for society season two i will never give
up like ever
ever i'm literally booking a flight to
silicon valley
heading to the netflix headquarters and
literally banging on their door
knock knock whose [ __ ] decision was
that somebody who should be fired
because they're obviously not in tune
with what's necessary obviously not good
at making decisions
no not at all and it's it still hurts
yeah well when does this hype house show
come out i don't know but like i'm kind
of excited
yeah that sounds like something that
that's in tune with what's necessary
like that's what the kids are up to i
feel like even when hype house was
popping off at the beginning of covid we
were like someone get a film crew in
there and like make it a reality show so
i just pushed it and watched all the
cool people left one year later someone
listened
yeah well that's what we do here in the
morning just tell people what to do
okay now i think without further ado it
is time for the past five stories that
you
yeah you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
blue nile at bluenile.com you can
celebrate all of life's special moments
from creating the custom engagement rank
of someone's dreams
to gifting a once in a lifetime piece
all up prices you won't find at
a traditional jeweler so bluenile.com
sells really the most stunning fine
jewelry diamond jewelry cocktail rings
tennis bracelets
gold layering jewelry etc um
and it's so stunning i actually got a
gorgeous pair of hoops mini hoops
from blue nile.com and they're just
beautiful and they're very um
elegant and it's really not like
anything i've seen in the jewelry
world right now they're so stunning i
think we got the same pair they're like
lit medium sized rainbow hoops these
beautiful stones
that are so beautiful so whether you're
marking a milestone or simply
celebrating in general bluenile.com
offers fine jewelry perfect
for every occasion and their spring
jewelry trends are in full bloom
whether you're looking for a statement
piece or everyday elegance bluenile.com
has fine jewelry for every occasion
so they're super credible they have a
long history they have over 165 000
ratings and counting
with 90 at four stars or higher blue
nile is committed to ensuring that the
highest ethical standards are observed
when they source
their diamonds and jewelry each diamond
is gia graded which allows you to view
the unique qualities which is carrot
color and cut
and be confident of the quality you are
buying blue nile is different from their
competitors because they don't mark up
to mark down
bluenile.com every at bluenile.com's
everyday prices are competitive to other
online retailers
sale prices they also have legendary
services with expert advice
24 7 30 day returns when you commit to a
piece so does blue nile they have
guaranteed service and repair
for life so if you're kind of reckless
like me you can feel good shopping at
blue nile
um make the moment sparkle with jewelry
from blue
nile dot com and the morning toast
listeners get 50
off your fur off your purchase of over
500
so this exclusive uh offer is only good
for the morning toast listeners
use code toast code
toast at bluenile.com
check it out go to bluenile.com today
shop stress fee with guaranteed free
shipping and returns
find your forever piece love it okay
first story
some big digital news prince william and
kate middleton launch a youtube
channel prince william and kate are
bringing the monarchy to youtube
the duke and duchess of cambridge
launched their youtube channel on
wednesday with a 25 second video montage
of the couple at various philanthropic
events and galas
he said by the way you have to be
careful what you say now because these
guys they're filming everything
she says i know the compilation ends
with kate candidly telling her husband
you didn't need to roll your r's he says
do i not fans will also get to see clips
of the royal family including queen
elizabeth and william and kate's three
children prince george
princess charlotte and prince louie so
i'm feeling kind of conflicted about
this let me tell you why because i do
feel like and what i've learned from the
crown is that queen elizabeth has been
really instrumental
in ushering the royal family into a new
generation the 21st century and
this like they have instagrams like i
get it something about this just feels
like it's been taken too far
okay i was really surprised because i
saw this news first i watched their
little teaser video and i was like this
is so cute it reminds me of
when we saw in the crown like how queen
elizabeth like invited like tv cameras
into her home and it was like
it was a shock to everyone but it was
like tv is the future and we're going to
be a part of the future so to me this
just feels like
it's like history joining the 21st
century 2021 like
we're on youtube now and yes and they
they are on instagram so they obviously
are embracing social media
but then i read the comments on the
instagram the morning toast instagram
post and people are so not here for this
like they think that it's like
kate and will are going to be doing like
drunk get ready with me and like doing
like classic i wish
classic youtube content which i don't
think that they're gonna do no it's
gonna be like they're
like boring like everyday work like you
know going to visit
like different you know organizations
like it's just gonna be like
it's not gonna be classic youtube
content it's honestly just going to be
like what they do on television every
time they go visit their royal tours
visiting
villages like yeah it's just going to be
that it's just like another place
for them to upload these videos that
they're already taking yeah so i didn't
think it was like that
big of a deal that they're starting a
youtube channel i mean if she starts
doing like cooking tutorials and like
how to use the tyson air app i would
watch that she needs to do
a blowout tutorial for everyone for
everyone and honestly if they don't give
the people what they need i am [ __ ]
unsubscribing
yeah so i was personally here for this
and i read the comments i was like oh
okay i guess like
i'm not well
i don't agree with everyone else and i i
get what people are like this is a weird
move like if
if you expect them to be like doing
youtube content but i think like they
have camera crews that follow them
they're always making these little
videos they post a lot of videos on
their instagrams and stuff
this just seems like a new place to
upload their existing like
kind of boring video content i think
that the concept of them having a
youtube channel is not bizarre at all
like
companies have youtube channels it's not
just people anymore it's not just
influencers like i
i don't think that's weird i just think
like the fact that they haven't had one
already now they're like launching it
and makes of course all this drama like
with all the megan and harry stuff like
this just feels like thirsty to me i
don't know but they're not thirsty
they're the royal family
there's just something weird about it i
can't put my finger on it that's what it
is
got it i at first didn't read it as
thirst but upon seeing that others did i
see where they're coming from i just
don't expect them to
to do the things that we would normally
expect from each and i
love will and kate like i literally
stayed up in high school but william
so like five in the morning to watch
their wedding like i literally love them
and so it's hard for me you know to
speak out against but i just don't think
that this is it
i just think that this is not as big of
a deal as as it seems it's just it's
like
they're just uploading videos i know but
you can't deny you must trust your gut
when you send me that link i'm like what
the [ __ ] like
it really free and i can't tell you why
it just felt so odd that's so funny
because i sent it to you as like with
excitement
and i was like excitement excites me i
received it with like
confusion and shadiness interesting so
it was just like our
first impressions miscommunicating we're
so different yeah
um also they changed their instagram
handle from kensington royal to duke and
duchess of cambridge and that's what
their youtube channel name is
and so i guess they're like going
through a re-brand as a couple just like
which makes sense i mean now it's like
why was it ever called kensington royals
nobody knows what that is just because
that's where they live like nobody
well actually probably people in london
and like who live in the television
palace
no people kensington oh yeah just like
it's just confusing there's so many
homes there's so many palaces there's so
many
and as much as like they are like the
leaders of the
commonwealth they are global figures and
like i don't know the different homes
right and so for me they should have
changed it yes so duke and duchess of
cambridge
are gonna lead with that sounds good so
what's the instagram handle duke and
duchess it's long it fits
damn it fits nice i guess where else can
really do anything they want
yeah so and this winter break i want
jordan i want that instagram handle
um so it's a new era i'm i'm i'm excited
we really don't know much about their
personalities like
no not at all but i also haven't like
spent that much time like
looking for their personalities yeah i
feel like so
we shall see very exciting are you ready
for our next story
i am lori harvey put her boyfriend
michael b jordan on a skincare regimen
hello lori harvey is making boyfriend
michael b jordan the face of her
forthcoming skincare line
the model revealed in a video for vogue
that the actor has been serving as her
live test model ahead of the launch
she said i tested all my products of
course on myself but i also tested them
on my boyfriend
he has become my live test model so now
he's very into his skincare routine as
well
she also said he tells me all the time
that when he's on set the makeup artists
complement his skin now
that is so beautiful i know like i
really don't
want to believe the people who like so
are convinced that like their
relationship is like so fake pr but like
this article interview like gives me
that vibe a little bit
oh but i like ship them so hard i don't
i don't want to believe it and i never
did believe it i haven't heard anything
like that that this is i heard it once
but but i never
i believe in it i believe i believed in
it too but this article's giving me like
a little like
sean and camilla like you know but shawn
and camilla are so real
i know but like but yeah you know what
i'm saying yeah i hear what you're
saying i didn't read it again i didn't
read it that way i just thought it was
like we're just like reading things
differently like it's and i feel like
yesterday
i feel like yesterday too oh leah's
outfit we read differently oh and i
think people agree with me
no for sure but like i just feel like
our we can always come
at the end we get on the same page but
it's just like you saw this story and i
saw the story and we had
totally different reactions no and maybe
it's just like the way that you read
this particular interview but i'm like
this is so fake no because it's like
when you read these quotes and when
someone's writing it up it seems like so
kelly's
yeah but if she's just doing her vogue
youtube tutorial and she's like i'm
starting a skincare routine and i'm
testing out my boyfriend like
that's cute you know it it definitely is
maybe i just feel like it's like
fraudulent because she's just like
pushing her makeup
so like that's why maybe it's not about
the relationship maybe it's just like
like marketing yeah it's all of those
things yeah
no and like i really do believe in them
the pictures of them are so cute and
same parts and i have a ship
built out to sea for them it's already
gone and they're literally on it taking
photos and paddle boarding
it's so cute sickening we don't even
need to ship them because they've
already they've byost
they've brought their own chip um but
speaking of skincare i saw a commercial
on tv
yesterday for jlo beauty and it was
literally like
i think they built jlo beauty like when
her and a-rod were still together and i
feel like he definitely helped her get
like crazy investors because it was just
like the most expensive commercial i'd
ever seen in my life
her skin looked i was literally about to
buy jayla beautyjlbeauty.com like
her skin looked like honey like
what was the premise of the commercial
just promoting she's like it's
do you remember we were growing up there
were those cindy crawford commercials
like people for years have asked me
about my skin it was kind of like a
infomercial do you remember them no oh
well it was like the most beautiful
woman in the world
is giving away her beauty secrets here
they are buy it at hsn.com or whatever
the commercial was giving me like that
kind of vibe because she was like for
years people have asked me about my
skincare and honestly i couldn't find it
all in one place
so you know what i did i did it myself
and she was like i took my grandmother's
olive oil extract
formula and formulated it into our olive
oil skincare
and it was just like stunningly done for
like
a celebrity brand like celebrities and
influencers even their successful brands
like have that stigma
it was literally like lemaire like it
was so wow
elegant i was like damn i don't love the
name jlo beauty
it's just like a celebrity brand yeah
whereas i really feel like that
she must have like a huge backer like
some company or some person
she her and aaron must have like raised
money for it because it's like really
professionally well done
and so i just felt like the name was
like a little i was trying to think of
like what i would have called it like i
would have called it like jlab
jayla beauty you know like something
else better jayla beauty is like not a
good name
okay but it was like a fancy it was like
an expensive commercial oh i can't wait
to see but then i'm totally gonna be
influenced and that's just like the last
thing i need
i know because it's also it's price like
lemare it's very expensive
they're priced no but it's priced like
lancome
like i don't think they would sell it at
ulta maybe they do actually i'm speaking
out of turn but it's like expensive it's
high high-end high-end interesting yeah
and the packaging is like
sickening but i just can't get i just
don't like the name it's like bothering
me oh i'm sorry
but i feel like that's her thing i think
she did like shoes for a while and it's
like how
kim did all these things until she found
skims and like that was her niche
i think jlo has found her niche talk i
think this is going to be the thing that
takes her into the billionaire
stratosphere
wow okay what an endorsement i can't
wait to check it out
and before i mention i've never tried or
seen a product in my life but like
that's
that's some great marketing yeah no the
marketing is working like i'm gonna get
something you've been marketed now i've
been speaking about it like maybe i
could just get a pr package things i'm
really in need of like a good eye cream
and hydration
multiplier yeah oh share with me yeah
okay our next story is so sick and
disgusting
um someone that we never really talk
about josh duggar was arrested last week
yeah and covered it on the toes oh sorry
i wasn't it was a duplicate story no no
no no
now he's out on bail and he had more
than 200
images of child sexual abuse material on
his computer say the authorities
also um the agent described multiple
torrent files downloaded from a child
abuse series
he described as within the top five of
the worst of the worst
that he has ever examined oh my gosh
this story gives me such a pit i've
never watched the duggars me neither i'm
so
so proud of that i never have been a
duggar
sluggers i don't know what the fans call
themselves i mean i did end up on duggar
tick tock there's like a lot of people
like
super invested in this family yeah no a
lot of people they do they actually have
19 kids
is it that's what the show is called 19
kids and counting so like the two
parents jim bob
and billy bob what are their they have
19
that's what they have 19 kids are like
with all the grandkids no i think it's
night because when the show started none
of them were like
married with kids okay so i think jim
bob i think that's his name and i don't
know the wife's name
theresa whatever i think that they have
19 kids which is
just honestly not to be judgmental
it's insane like who needs that many
kids
and i believe in big families like 19
really have 19 kids
they have 20. i guess they had one more
oh they adopted the 20th when the show
had already are there any twins or
triplets
i do believe there are but like have you
i actually i take it back i have seen
some episodes of the show because i
remember being taken aback by their
sleeping arrangements like with
so many kids like it was a bump like
but in a bedroom it was actual
pandemonium wow that's crazy
and that's just i think really
indicative of the state of our like
culture that like people
were obsessed with the duckers before
they found out about the sex
the child abuse let me tell you why this
is so upsetting obviously because the
crime itself is so important and
disgusting like
vile the worst of the worst like we knew
you know like years ago there were all
these allegations from the other
siblings
i think one of the older girls is no
longer associated with the family and
she and her husband do youtube videos
and they said that like to support the
lgbtq and like literally quake to the
duggars down like
so they're like kind of broken from that
but when we all heard josh duggar got
arrested like what did we think it was
for like we all knew what it was gonna
be
yeah so it just seems like this because
we all knew like this is something that
could and should have been avoided
yeah and just like so he's out on bail
now but
there was a virtual detention hearing
for his charges
and the prosecutors say he had more than
200 images of children on his computer
and that they were
some of the worst they've ever seen and
i did see an article that said like he
should be allowed to be released on bail
because he's not a flight risk because
he's so
famous and recognizable that like a star
like him could impossibly run away
without being noticed it's like
josh tugger have a seat that's not a
thing
shut the [ __ ] down free yeah this is so
upsetting and so disgusting and just
like i honestly like
hate this family yeah and this man yeah
agreed
are you ready for our next story yeah
good news oh the good news brought to
you
you guys today's a huge lovingly brought
to you it's a huge day here at the
morning toast because
because because the real ones will know
real ones will know
today's sponsor is back
scentbird is back and i've been waiting
for a promo code because i need a refill
yeah
we were just talking about how we don't
wear enough perfume we need to get
back on the performance and we're going
to try different perfumes and send bird
said
we hear you we see you and we got you we
have your back
scentbird is a fragrant subscription
service that gives you the opportunity
to shop from over 600 brands
it is a flexible subscription so you can
skip any month without penalties
they let you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
and every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises
they have perfumes and colognes and a
lot of unisex options
how it works is that you choose the
perfume you want to try they'll send you
a 30 day supply
it's literally the best size like it's
so travel friendly
it's if you like it great if you don't
like it it's not a huge bottle it's
really fabulous
and they carry the most sickening
designer brand save prada gucci versace
they also have indie labels like vince
camuto the harmonist and confessions of
a rebel
and all of them are 100 authentic they
work directly with the brands
but if you're not sure what type of
scent you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance by brand
style occasion season and more
and some bottles of perfume can cost
anywhere from 150 to 500
even more because like semper carries um
i might be pronouncing this wrong but
amuse a mouse cost
once from the harmonics can cost 295
dollars sicily for 280 and so on
so literally semper is an absolute
no-brainer
and it's 60 a month but if you decide
you want to get the full size
um you can purchase it and we have a
code it'll be only 11
for your first month so exclusive offer
just for our listeners you can get 30
off your first month today that's only
11 for your first fragrance
go to scentbird.com use our code toast
for 30 off your first month again that's
s-c-e-n-t
bird.com for you to try your first
perfumer cologne for just eleven dollars
smell amazing oh it feels good so good
good just say that it feels good it
smells good
it is good it is good morning honestly
i feel like we should release a
fragrance called good that's a good idea
that's a good idea let's talk december
like it just
let's talk to somebody or like i by the
way i'm dead serious i think we need a
perfume i think we do
too because we both need a signature
fragrance and also the bottle could be
like a sickening palm leaf or something
yeah and it smells good wait by the way
i don't know how we've never thought of
doing a fragrance before
i'm so excited and then we'll partner
with some bird
sure for them to put part of the samples
and by the way toast is a great name
for a fragrance but so it's good
good by toast good toast toasty goodness
good bye toast fragrances love that amad
that is our next business proposal i'm
i'm on it i'm so excited
are you excited for our next story i'm
so
excited i'm hyping it up like a lot no
no it's it's good news
for new york for actors actresses
broadway
will reopen at full capacity in new york
city on september 14th
september okay they could open sooner
but they need time to propose the shows
to practice
to wait for tourists to come back so
even though a lot of things in new york
will be opening up
um july july and also may 16th is a date
that's floating around of things like
coming back
um they need time so the day that it
will all be ready september 14th and i
think we should go see a show but that's
just me
i'm literally sitting front row at
wicked like i [ __ ] love wicked
oh that's the one you would want to see
i think so what are you
i hadn't thought about it i was thinking
something that i'd never seen before
like yeah but but we might as well go
with something i know i'm going to love
and honestly if you still can be with
the wizard
why did you want to do that and then
maybe i could wear this hat to the party
tonight
if you don't wear a hat to the party
tonight i'm not talking to you
okay done done do you want to twist my
arm
no that's exciting i mean it's actually
crazy because it's like great broadway's
back but like these are professional
actors they actually need like weeks to
train
yes so they're having those weeks now
tickets are expected to go on sale on
thursday and tourists usually account
for 65
of annual live theater ticket sales in
the city but like it's not a super
tourist attraction right now so that's
the date
okay i mean if you're a broadway fan
from out of town like
start planning support local uh theater
artists
yeah and you too can still
be with the wizard what you've hoped
and waited for you could have
all you've ever wanted
that was really good and really like
sweet you sound like a kid
like who got cast like like in the
nutcracker you know thank you claudia
thanks but i don't want it no
i can't want it
anymore
alfie just say you're sorry
no [ __ ] i'm out of here give me my
broom you guys you don't have to go to
broadway actually you can just watch the
morning toast
no literally alphabet and glenda
literally
we are literally elf england we
literally are
wait are we literally alphabet england
or figuratively
we're physically and literally and
mentally
virtually are you ready for our fifth
and final story some more good news
final story
[Music]
day it's actually it's a really good
intro
because spacex has landed a mars rocket
prototype for the first time this is
some big
good space news good for elon good for
space
spacex just launched another test flight
of an early mars rocket prototype at its
south texas facility
sending the towering silver vehicle
roaring up to about six miles above
earth then putting it through a series
of aerial acrobatics before re-lighting
two of its edges put it through a series
of areolas
that's what i thought you were gonna say
really yeah
before relighting two of its engines and
landing it upright back on a landing pad
so like can i be honest no
yeah like i just like really don't give
a [ __ ] like until
somebody like you know builds a house on
mars and like i can go visit it
like i really don't care i know it's
important and i'm not
these things need to happen in order to
get to a place where houses are built
and like me and the me and the aliens
are chilling like i get it but like
i'm just not interested it's like i
thought we already did this
like yeah but it's baby steps you know
i know it's one small step
for man one large leap for mankind well
yeah
big leap for mankind can we talk about
that i don't really understand
oh it's a small step for the man who's
the man who stepped on the moon it was a
small step for him but it was a
leap for mankind just got chills i never
understood that
that's beautiful do you think that he
thought of what he was going to say
before
yes i do remember reading somewhere i
feel like i remember
that they had it was such a momentous
moment that they had planned like what
the first words on the moon were going
to be as it should be because like if he
just kind of like
spit yeah it's just like he's just like
babbling on
it's like wow this guy should have been
a philosopher
has landed on the socrates landed on the
moon yeah
do you know who claimed those immortal
words
neil armstrong um okay well that's cool
like i guess i'm happy for him
i just like some good news like going
into his big weekend hosting snl maybe
he'll mention it
so yeah i think we should talk about
that because i'm still not convinced
that i shouldn't buy more doge because
elon musk is going to
like blow doge and doge is already up so
much right now you know what
buy more doge right now hold on it'll
take me one second how much do you spend
the first time
200 i think you should spend another
200. i think that's what i was planning
on doing
just do it but it's like i bought it in
at 0.04 and now it's at point six but
you know i'm doing it
it's still like point six what if one
day it gets to one or two hundred
right that's right then should i just do
like a million
200 more dollars it's really like fine
sending order great done
okay so now i have
i'm not i don't understand how any of
this works but to the moon
literal to the moon and mars
yeah one step for dogecoin is that one
large leap for claudia
huge you have no idea like this money
could change my life um
but what i was going to say about snl is
that like i'm just really
i'm kind of over like everyone like
being so upset about elon musk like
these cast mates who are like all for
clamped it's like are you serious like
you get to meet one of the greatest
minds of our time okay maybe you don't
know general albert einstein is going on
snl
this is why like i don't really agree
with my channel albert go albert
it's your birthday go albert go elon
go elon it's your birthday go ela
no like this is where i just don't
really like under like agree with my
generation and like my culture sometimes
it's like
okay i'm still not 100 sure like why
elon musk is considered controversial
but i guess it has a lot to do with um
like the environment i really don't know
um but okay people may have legitimate
gripes with him but like we're really
gonna like not
like let him host snl like like we're
just gonna let like i just i just can't
get on the same
i literally can't even speak because i
just don't understand why these people
are so bent out of shape about yes
but i just want to say that um elon musk
was spotted going out to dinner with
some of the snl castmates and he said
that it's been awesome so far preparing
for the show and these are the cast
mates
that he did was spotted at dinner with
okay like
definitely not bow and yang or eddie
bryant right no of course not wait
brian isn't even on wait is she honest
and i'll still yeah okay sorry
i thought she left pete davidson thank
god
colin jost keenan thompson
chris redd kate mckinnon oh shoot nope
chloe feynman
live for her eggo note him okay that's
good that's good
i'm glad that he's making friends like
you're going to dinner so like sad
because like as much as it's like this
big popular thing you spend the whole
week with these people and like you want
them to like you
yeah and i think some of them probably
do like him some of them are outspoken
against him and i'm pretty sure lauren
said if any of them don't want to
do that that they don't have to no i
know i'm like why is that even a thing
like i'm just
i refuse to go down a rabbit hole of
like why elon musk is bad like because
if there's stuff there like i just don't
want to know but as far as i know he's a
genius like genus
say and do crazy things yeah it's part
of the geniosity like
hello i'm a genius that's why i'm always
getting in trouble yeah totally i'm
so excited for snl me too i should like
watch together even though it sounds so
late i have a party like i'm really not
even gonna be able to watch it live
oh but i will be watching my robin hood
live i think i'll watch
live 100 what are you gonna go to bed
no do your plans no i don't have plans
i'm going to like a full-blown like
cocktail party because you know
i've said this a million times like
we're living in a post-pandemic world
do not look for me yeah i don't want to
be found no i'm in my nose i'm on the
edge of a cliff
i'm with norma kamali i'm touching
everyone like that's where i
am physically and emotionally do not
look for me
no ever we are not we won't only from
10 to 12 are we looking for you know
monday through friday like i can mostly
be found and i'm not against being found
but
mostly maybe like thursday night to
monday morning like do not even attempt
to look for me like i'm okay
don't want to be found great don't worry
thank you i got you i'll cover for you
um let's dive into our tv recap the real
housewives of new jersey was on last
night
and it was a fine episode but the
watchtop and side special afterward was
really like what we should be talking
about
this tv recap segment is brought to you
by nuts.com an incredible website that
you have to kept at
check out nuts.com is the best kept
secret of savvy snackers across
the country they have a variety of super
high quality delicious snacks they have
white chocolate toffee cashews bourbon
pecans pecans whatever
crystallized ginger honey sesame sticks
they have great dried fruit
nuts chocolates they have amazing snacks
and if you are
a snack kind of connoisseur always
looking for new snacks in your pantry
you gotta check out nuts.com it's not
just for nut lovers because
i don't really even die for nuts um but
is your one stop online pantry shop
um they have so many different varieties
of snacks pantry items like candies
dried fruits
pantry items like baking mixes pasta and
more
it's so fun to shop on you try things
you never thought you would try and
they're
so delicious our whole studio is like
stocked with stuff
you are snacks by nuts.com it's not just
nuts it's literally every snack under
the sun and everything is such
premium delicious high quality candy
dried fruits nuts whatever it is you can
find it at nuts.com and that way you
don't have to like
go shopping at a million places for all
the snacks that you want and it's like
high quality artisanal stuff you won't
even find in the grocery store
one stop shop for quality snacking they
have over 4 000 products to choose from
plus delicious healthy kid family snacks
like dried strawberries custom trail mix
plus all the raw organic roasted salted
and candied nuts you can imagine even
chocolate dipped if you want to treat
yourself to something like so delicious
like a sweet treat in your home
might i suggest the white chocolate
truffle cashews
i believe that's what they are they have
gluten-free and vegan options they have
super fast delivery most orders ship on
the same day and their products are
fresher than the supermarket
um so if you want to be a new nuts.com
customer you can get free shipping on
your first order when you text toast
to 64 000. so text toast to 64 000
to get free shipping on your first order
from nuts.com
that's t-o-a-s-t to 64
000 terms apply available at nuts.com
terms
sign on go nuts go nuts
okay let's see nuts if you're not
shopping at nuts.com that should be
their new slogan
um real housewives in new jersey was
like low-key boring because jackie's
party got like imploded from like
dolores didn't want to come and then
like melissa had to go because joe was
in the hospital and
she felt so sad for jackie i thought it
was a trip because they were going to
glenn your mansion
and then all the women showed up without
suitcases and so i was like oh it's a
day trip and they're going to drive it
so far
to drink and then drive back like
torture torturous day she should have
just celebrated
she should have just you know done one
of her classic pizza parties in the long
on the basketball court yeah
yeah um so i like felt bad for her but
like loved the drama of kidney stones
and i loved
that delores was like tell david to go i
mean tell
joe to go to patterson hospital that's
where david is today and i'll send him
over
and like of course the night before joe
was being such a prick to
delores about david and then david
someone taking care of him passing his
kidney stones
and i've never had have you never had a
brush with kidney stone i don't know
anyone who's had one
but they sound painful because joey had
one on friends
yeah really painful i just want to say
in the battle of dolores versus everyone
i'm on dolores
side completely of course everyone is
just like being so nosy and by the way
like
yeah she said this last season and she
said that this season and you guys are
like so confused but like
she said from the beginning of the
season that she's happy she looks happy
she seems happy i would not question her
happiness if i was her friend
she looks like she's in such a good
place she looks like she's in the best
place out of maybe all of them when she
was
having her kids dinner that was for
their birthday
so nice and then when she said like he
shows up when it counts yeah he doesn't
come to these like dumb housewives [ __ ]
if you guys want to be on the show but
like that's not as important to her it's
like you're showing up for my kid's
birthday like he shows up when it
matters and those things don't matter
i heard you dolores i see you 100 yes
because
jackie when dolores stormed out of the
party at melissa's house no
is her name melissa that girl michelle
michelle i'm like no there's not two
melissa's
um jackie was like you know just last
year she said she wanted a ring and like
now i guess she doesn't he just never
got the update
and i was like okay i guess that's a
good point and then marge was like no we
didn't get the update but like we all
know we just listened to her and like we
got it like she doesn't need to write it
out
and once again like march just like
speaking facts being the true moral
compass of the show the only one who's
being
who didn't participate in the poll and
who's being a good friend to
delores like i'm so on team dolores all
the other women are so annoying
jennifer's so [ __ ] annoying like
i try to like her because she's like
great tv but like my god she's such a
bad friend and she's so annoying
and she's supposed to be she has been
like blindly loyal to teresa and dolores
this whole time and now she's just being
a pain in the ass cause she feels like
it
yeah also i'm so excited to see her
renovate her home
uh jennifer yeah and it looks great i
love the furniture is that the z gallery
couch
it didn't look so similar to our couch
but
her whole aesthetic was giving me z
gallery advice would definitely see
i think it's the sea gallery luca couch
that we have i loved that whole how she
like kind of split her living room up
into two living rooms i loved the
big ass coffee table it was stunning
like that will be inspo for me one day
yeah no it must be so nice to just like
have a revamp
and your home was so weird looking
before yeah
and i didn't really notice until like
they were all going over there in the
last week's episode and
jackie was like uh this is like the taj
mahal at the taj mahal
mortgage and no furniture and it reminds
me of teresa's
yeah like big house no furniture i
wonder
i just saw teresa tick talking in her
old house so i guess she hasn't moved
out and bought a new one yet
she did buy the one she bought one yeah
but she hasn't moved out or
maybe the other one hasn't sold maybe um
because i'm really excited for this new
chapter for her
me too like i actually was thinking how
in the beginning of the season she was
bothering me so much and i couldn't
imagine watching another episode
with her being the star and now that
she's like in this happy place she's not
fighting with anyone and she's just
talking about like her boyfriend
she it really does does go to prove like
she's been such a miserable person these
last few years because she's been going
through miserable things
and now that like a lot of that has
subsided she definitely is like a better
person for it
so as much as i've been annoyed at
everyone like giving her a pass all
these seasons it's like
she really hasn't always been this
animal like she was just going through
so much yeah they were doing a lot of
flashbacks anything was melissa who said
like theresa
has not been happy in 10 years in her
opinion and when they flashed back to
like 2009 so like more than 10 years ago
when they moved into the house and the
girls were so little and it was before
all the
um stuff she was like a completely
different person yeah she was still like
saying dumb things like starting
fighting she was just but like
sucks the life out of her every room
person and that's who she's become but
she's really on the other side of it now
like with her boyfriend
and and joe is so happy for her and i
know she's getting annoyed at joe for
like
spilling the beans but like how can he
not be excited she's been in a miserable
marriage
for so long and in a miserable legal
battle situation for the last eight
years like you have to be happy for her
you really do
yeah and i'm happy for her and i can
like move forward now i've moved on from
the
jackie and evan's stuff so has jackie
and so has evan yeah but
now i'm moving forward but i watch watch
what happens live last night which we
need to talk about but i feel like
everyone's always sort of like
putting like teresa jackie and evan like
in the same like
like there's something weird there's
something weird theresa like would
literally do anything to [ __ ] evan and
that's what i
think i don't disagree there's some and
she also like
kind of wants [ __ ] brother um but the
watch weapons are special which they've
been doing the specials every day this
week last
uh episode was last night was um all the
real housewives of new york the night
before that
was blast from the past so they had like
people who used to have shows on bravo
and last night was um house husbands of
new jersey the real house hospitals of
new jersey they did like a special intro
for the show where they did like a mock
tagline it was so good frank's was like
i don't know where these other men rank
but there's a reason they call me big
frank
and bill when bills was like i'm the
only bill my wife takes care of
no the only bill my hus my wife is
responsible for i'm the only bill my
wife is responsible for
joe benigno was like i wear the pants
but my wife picks out the shirt no like
these are better than housewife
joe uh gorgas was so lame like we get it
your wife has a store called envy
you may envy my wife but wait till you
see my
life lame yeah um and evans was the only
thing i do at the gym is turn heads why
do i remember every single one of these
no and also
why is evan still talking about the gym
like well i think they probably wrote
that for him and that's literally the
only notable thing he's really
contributed
or it can't be about how he doesn't get
[ __ ] my wife may not blow me but
maybe the girl at the gym will like
something like that
um and it was a great episode it's
actually just a really interesting
dynamic how there's so many fights
amongst the women
and when andy asks them about the
different fights like they do disagree
but someone asks they're like how do you
guys stay like best friends
but your wives fight and like it doesn't
affect you and they were like we really
just don't like care
yeah no they all like agree with their
wives and no one
did not defend their wife and nobody
gets mad at the other man for nothing
they obviously like have this pact and
like made an agreement
early on like whatever goes on with
these women like even when like they
started fighting at the jersey shore and
then just got it from the table like
they're not interested they don't care
and i loved it i think they also
just have like a good sense about them
to be like this is
our wives jobs like it's really not that
personal most of the time so just let
them do their thing
i can their relationships change as much
as the ladies like
it would always be they couldn't keep up
yeah but i just like loved it and
honestly like
i last night like i think i actually had
a dream
because i like fell in love with frank
catania like all over again
the way he was just like talking about
dolores who he's not even married to but
he was just like
defending her so wholeheartedly like
i don't know he was just like saying the
sweetest things about her and like i
just like [ __ ]
i really do like i ship them so hard
it's crazy but like wow it'll never
happen
why can't he stop cheating like right no
she said like i'll never get back with
him because i'll never be able to really
forgive him for what he did and he said
i would never get back with her because
because i can't guarantee that i
wouldn't cheat on her
are you [ __ ] kidding me like that's
crazy but they just love each other so
much and like i'm telling you if they
tried like there's something there
who no i love their modern family i love
david i think he gives dolores that
stability that she needs frank is like
family at this point they're literally
like brother and sister
you know what i mean about it so hard in
that way like they're family
but they're not like in love but when
they like show pictures of like when the
kids were really young and they were
taking these family portraits like they
were so adorable like
such a jersey couple yeah so who's your
favorite
okay let's go through evan is not my
favorite but he is the one i would
definitely
like [ __ ] um love jumping now he's up
there
and why was annie calling him joe benino
is that how it's pronounced i don't
think so when andy like said
to frank did you just did you get botox
i was shocked because i didn't even
notice it but his forehead literally
didn't move no i know and then he i'm
glad he came clean because everyone
would have been like oh so you're a liar
that's so lame
yeah um okay so honestly it's between
frank or joe and
benigno and i might have to say frank
yeah frank or or also bill ayden
i love bill aidan but on the episode he
was like giving me nothing he was like
not even talking and he was very nervous
such a class act
like so classy he like every he had an
answer for everything
i think like he's like in the drama but
so above it
i might go bill no and he literally
frank for me and he
and his wife is so indefensible of all
the women i think she's the one who's
the most indefensible besides theresa
but she didn't have a husband there
i think and i have a lot of respect for
the fact that he didn't waver he's like
no i think jennifer should have said
that like when like literally he's such
a reasonable man he obviously doesn't
think that no but like he's a good
husband first
like the whole house husband thing like
drives teresa crazy because like she
thinks it's her show but like literally
i tune in for the men
no i don't think so i think she likes
like being surrounded by the guys like i
don't
and she just finds another way to like
make it about her also maybe eventually
like louie will be part
that's what i was thinking the group and
then like is he gonna be
i don't know why he wouldn't be like
he's he posts on instagram and stuff
joe loves him and everyone says like
they're so serious like they would get
married and if david can be on the show
like
i think louis should be too no of course
but it's about hey does he want to be a
part of it and be like will the men
like want to be brothers poker night
with him because they said
uh andy was like why don't you guys you
have such this clique like why not david
like david is the one who's actually
dating dolores and they said they invite
him to everything but he
works and i just honestly i think what
they're not saying is that he just
doesn't want to be on the show
that much he does it because dolores
loves it it's dolores his work
and he does the bare minimum but he just
doesn't want to do it and i can respect
that someone who's like a doctor and
like
has a like a serious life totally i'm
i'm very happy with the situation at
hand and also like if louie does join
the boys and like
he's able to just jump right in and
everybody likes him like that will be a
ringing endorsement oh of course but
when when melissa was like this is
literally her husband i'm like
no like she doesn't want to be single
for like a little bit longer she was
just trapped in this like
awful marriage i don't think she was
like even when she was married or
getting divorced like she was never like
excited to be single like she's just
excited she was excited to be in love
and be
loved and get [ __ ] yeah but also just
like
to be with someone that is just like so
happy to be with her
so she's found that so it doesn't matter
whether she's single or in a
relationship like
she's feeling loved and so i don't think
she needs to go and be single again
that's actually a fair point
well it was good episode i really loved
the watch robin's live tonight is
um like former housewives jill zarin's
on it i think
uh gretchen oh wow
yeah they're getting better and sunday
night um taylor armstrong on it i hope
so
and i think phaedra is on it i saw pedro
very quickly like faces yes and i'm
trying to remember
and then sunday is the real house kids
which i'm very excited for yeah
they really should have found a way to
do it all in studio especially because
like especially the new york the
husbands are in new jersey the
the jersey women the jersey men could
have done it the new york women could
have done it the kids it's like 30 kids
and half of them live around the country
that i understand but the fact that they
could have had tri-state area kids they
could have had tri-state area kids
um i'm very much looking forward to that
and tonight is keeping up with the
kardashians which hopefully is not as
boring as it's been
and summer house part two reunion so i'm
very excited oh i guess i won't be
caught up in time is there a part three
no oh so then i guess i missed the
season but i do plan on watching because
i trust your endorsement no it's so good
cool um and that's our show anything
else you wanna talk about before we
bounce
no everyone enjoy your thursday next
time we see you it will be friday and
that's just
an exciting thing to think about so
don't forget to acknowledge the space
that you are currently in
it's the best possible space it's the
spring weekend it's the snitch's
birthday
fridays around the corner live it up
all right you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing thursday we will see you
tomorrow
for friday friday
gotta get down on friday